remember i told you
to send me some money for you
i refuse why did i refuse
why did i refuse
because you're an idiot
that was so uncalled for
i want you to take that instagram down
and keep it down i am not taking it down
and that is it
michael tells angela the only way he's
taking down his social media page his
feed and comments are filled with women
and who knows what the hell happens in
his dm
is if she gives him 5 000
oh he's growing balls okay okay he said
you're gonna have to pay me to get off
the ground michael's five thousand
dollar proposition
now raises the question
is this enough to officially call him a
scammer or is this just an act of
rebellion
i am not taking it down and that is it
okay
goodbye
you win your birthday
and oh yeah it's his birthday
happy birthday
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
you might have noticed we skipped a week
i was on vacation but now i'm back and
i'm ready to get into
all of this mess i don't even know if i
know like what this point a few things
before we get into angela and michael's
latest argument
you all know they argue all the time
i've been totally lost account during
the premiere episode of this season
elizabeth revealed she wants to pursue a
singing career
yeah it was a bit random i was like
she can sing
but supposedly it's always been a dream
of hers
in this episode we actually get to hear
her voice
down came the rain and washed the spider
out
out came the sun and dried up all the
rain and the itsy bitsy spider went up
the spout again
the boys coach gives her a few notes
about her pitch but she sounds good to
me to the untrained ear elizabeth you
got it girl
it felt so amazing to be back in a voice
lesson i am feeling more myself again
and
i just wanted to belt it out her plan
right now is to record nursery rhymes i
know that my daughter is interested in
it too because any time i sing she's
just like all about it yeah is that like
weird
but i'm thinking once her confidence
grows she'll decide to branch out a bit
and even if this doesn't go anywhere
i think it's cool that she has the
courage to admit that this is a dream of
hers especially at this point in her
life
that takes guts and oh yeah andre is in
full support of libby's dream well
watching libyan hearing her
i'm very happy i never interrupt her
when she's uh
singing even i don't like the song
it's pretty cool he basically just
admitted that he knows how rude he can
be
i i'm never into rap her when she's uh
singing even i don't like the song
it's it's pretty cool also
it was nice to meet you but i'm gonna go
cause your ass is pissing me off
[Music]
damn right kim storms off after usman
tells her he's now interested in having
three or four wives instead of the
already agreed upon too
so i threw a milkshake at him she's also
upset that he's now saying his other
wife or wives would be loved just as
much as she is
this is not what he told me in the past
he thinks it's funny he's talking about
this third and fourth wife uh-uh cause
i'll bail out now uh-uh tell him again
kim uh-uh cause i'll bail out now he
never finds fault with his own actions
everything's my fault all the time and
you get tired of it after a while and
you throw stuff
i get the frustration but kim let's not
make throwing things a habit
this is her second time throwing a drink
at usman
the last time she did it she said it was
the first time she's ever thrown a drink
at anyone i have never in any
relationship i've been in ever
resorted to throwing a drink in
someone's face
and kim i love you but it's a little
hard to believe at this point your ass
is pissing me off
huh if only she would go home and she
threatens to this episode and usman
tells her to go
but i'm thinking his love for the
spotlight i love being on tv
isn't allowing him to let her out of his
life that easy
out of this country
[Music]
listen don't touch me i'm telling you
don't touch me who's man i'm not playing
stop
leave me alone i'll do whatever i want
there is no yammy worth that in the
world
all right let's get into michael
blackmailing angela over his social
media
he asked me for money right after
christmas i told him no we got bills to
pay they come first
and when i told him no it just seems
like
i don't know what happened he started
putting his instagram up and then let me
show you what he's what he said
send me 5k i will take it down
i don't know right now if michael's just
being stupid
and trying to get my attention or is he
really just showing me his true damn
colors at this point angela has a huge
decision to make she hasn't seen michael
in two years and she needs to decide if
she still wants him to come to the
states even though he's been acting
differently toward her
because his visa can get approved any
day now michael could come with or
without my approval she says michael
switched up after they got married
specifically after she got all those
surgeries
i can tell you he was a butt he was a
total ass now i'm not sure if michael is
fed up with angela talking to him crazy
and doing whatever she wants to do
or if he's just over being a sweet
scammer and now he's just ready to get
to the money i want to try to fix things
because i love him but i can only hope
that michael's hurts in this
relationship for the right reasons it's
michael's birthday so angela gives him a
call and they both sound like this
relationship has turned into a job
that they're ready to quit hi michael
happy birthday
that was the driest happy birthday ever
happy birthday
thank you
you gonna go out for your birthday
i didn't go out today you know um
i mean i don't have more cash for me so
i have to stay at all for context angela
told michael he shouldn't work
and he listened
i send michael money so he can buy
groceries make payments on his car
because i'm the one that didn't want
michael to work because so many things
can go wrong in nigeria control control
remember i told you
to send me some money for you
i refuse why did i refuse
why did i refuse
because you're an idiot after all these
years of watching angela scream and
michael you would think i would be used
to it by now but
i'm not
you have been blessed all these four
years and now you want to be ungrateful
mother
i've always provided michael with enough
money to live on so he can make payments
on his car keep his phone on have a tv
so where's that damn money going if he's
asking for more
and he had the nerve to threaten me he
would take down his instagram only if i
sent him five thousand dollars now how
much shadier can he get
it sounds like michael is saying you can
no longer control me but that money can
get money angela continues to go off on
michael you blocked me on your instagram
you're talking to women on your ig
but it seems as if she's forgetting
she's also been talking to men on social
media
[Music]
the same man in this video
billy
appeared on last week's episode and
angela revealed she's going to try to go
see him in canada i emailed billy for a
painting that i wanted to have made for
mike and we befriended each other and
started dancing together on tick-tock
[Music]
but billy is not your typical dancer he
used to be in the 80s a male stripper
and his title was the original thief of
hearts
and boy does he still have the moves
and the looks
so it sounds like she's accusing michael
of doing what she's actually doing
do i need to bring keisha cole into this
you can't accuse me of
according to angela she's been posting
the videos with billy to help him get a
kidney because he has kidney failure but
from the sound of this laugh do you
still have the moves and the looks
there's definitely more to it all of a
sudden you get married and you've been
acting shabby
the bottom line is this angela wants to
control everything
it's not done that way
i just want
my opinion to count in marriage no make
decisions
and besides everyone in the world have
social media
you know she has social media so why is
he so a big deal
i mean it's
it's crazy
i hope all this stress is an aging
michael he seems tired but then again he
continues to sign up for it
i want you to take that instagram down
and keep it down
i am not taking it down and that is it
okay
goodbye you and your birthday
who can take that without snapping
clearly angela is losing control over
michael and
she's freaking out
since he's put his instagram up he's
become a social media [ __ ] his feed and
comments are filled with women and who
knows what the hell happens in his dm i
don't even know if i know like at this
point
but like clockwork
after she hangs up on him he calls her
right back but only to ask about his
visa which ticks angela off even more
you shouldn't be worried about when you
get here i caught because i wanted you
to know
we need to work on our marriage because
you don't do nothing that's going to
make us stay together why do i want to
bring you here
you have did nothing but hurt me
that's all you have done it's funny to
you i didn't do nothing for you to treat
me this way
i can't do this conversation i am over
this call
i'm done
that dog is like let me look the other
way
angela trying to control michael in this
relationship is proof that sometimes
when you put so much energy and effort
into trying to prevent something from
happening
you force it to happen because what you
give energy to grows
if you're constantly making decisions in
your relationship based on fear
how can you expect the relationship to
develop in a positive direction
math doesn't add up i'm not sure if this
would ever happen but it would be great
to see a show where some 90 day cast
members go to therapy and work through
what's actually holding them back from
having a healthy relationship
i will be down to watch that we can
learn a lot and this is also why i could
not be a producer on this show i would
be too busy in the background trying to
mediate shoot it gets to a point where
watching them stress becomes stressful
nobody's going to try to help me my
husband ain't talking to me my husband's
doing you're looking for attention that
michael's not giving you when it comes
to michael potentially being a scammer
angela's daughter skyla thinks that's
exactly what he is do you gotta fight
and play games to get somebody's
attention i don't think it's you know
worthwhile oh girl say that again
if you gotta fight and play games to get
somebody's attention i don't think it's
you know worthwhile um that's good
i really think she should just end it
with him honestly because i don't think
michael is playing the games to make her
jealous i really do think that you know
he's seen her as an opportunity to come
over here to america and
i think that you know he gained that
connection with her
and it's been easy to play her ever
since
easy
i beg to differ what do you think of
michael's actions telling angela to pay
him 5k if she wants him to take his
instagram down
is it safe to officially say that he's
been scamming her to get to america
i had a friend say that she thinks
they're scamming each other
michael to get to america and angela for
fame which is an interesting take me
i definitely think getting to america
has been a motivating factor in michael
staying in this relationship
but i also think a large part of his
attitude is due to angela speaking to
him like trash because you're an idiot
someone can only take that for so long
i need to fly my ass over there's
finally
now angela is planning on popping up on
michael in nigeria without telling him
she's coming
i gotta go over there to myself to see
if it's worth it anymore and from the
looks of the teaser for this season
it's gonna be a disaster
next week she starts to prepare for the
trip so when we get there and you see
michael you got to have a plan
he doesn't know i'm coming we're just
going to surprise him hello mother
if i found out michael was scamming me
i'm coming back and pulling visas and
i'm calling for divorce i'm not sure who
that other woman is but
i guess we'll find out
all right 90 days fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you